y
[Música]
en algunas regiones de malí subsiste una
forma de esclavitud de castas los
descendientes de los antiguos esclavos
siguen siendo víctimas de la
discriminación y de brutales ataques por
parte de los nobles es decir de sus
antiguos propietarios
esto es lo que ocurrió en el pueblo de
surubí d el pasado 28 de septiembre
cuando los descendientes de esclavizados
organizaban una fiesta y fueron atacados
hablamos con una de las víctimas y
transcribimos sus palabras para
preservar su anonimato
lebron como vive youtube para los nobles
empezaron a llegar de todas partes
tratando de impedir que tuviéramos
nuestra fiesta tenían palos y machetes
dijeron que nadie se mueva y los
esclavos no harán una fiesta en nuestro
pueblo
paramos la música empezará a lanzar
piedras hacia la fiesta e hirieron a la
gente tenían armas y dispararon al aire
para asustar todos intentamos subir pero
algunos no lo lograron
los nobles agarraron a otros los
golpearon los ácaros consiguió escapar y
esconderme en un campo algunos se
disculparon y se rindieron en techos
pero otros se defendieron y se negaron a
ser llamados escribas muchas personas
resultaron heridas y retuvieron a los
que capturaron durante ocho horas antes
de librados de willacy
la clase noble no tiene propiedad legal
de los esclavos pero a estos últimos no
se les permite casarse fuera de su casta
ni son elegibles para cargos directivos
los esclavos suelen vivir separados de
los demás durante las fiestas deben
sacrificar animales y también cocinar
para los nobles hablamos con muhammad y
kanoute miembro de la asociación contra
la esclavitud quien lucha por el fin de
este sistema de castas en más sabe lo
quiere y tasio
martín tonso existen muchas tensiones y
se han producido muchas agresiones
muchos malos tratos en los últimos años
hay personas que se oponen a la
esclavitud basada en la ascendencia se
han creado asociaciones hay individuos
que dicen que no son esclavos
hay esclavas para sundance de los que se
oponen a la esclavitud basada en la
ascendencia están expuestos a ataques
físicos violencia ataques planificados
sangrientos bárbaros e incluso mortales
por memo mártir y ha donado hemos visto
que han detenido a personas las han
atado como si fueran animales comunes
les dieron una paliza
incluso hay un joven muerto perdió la
vida porque le dispararon a la cabeza
esperamos que los autores o autores
cómplices y patrocinadores de esos actos
bárbaros e inhumanos no salgan impunes y
ni me viene
el número de miembros de la casta de los
esclavos suele ser mayor que el de la
casta de los nobles y muchos no se
atreven a sublevarse por miedo a la
influencia de los nobles en las
autoridades locales e incluso en la
policía muchos también nos dijeron que
no querían rebelarse por miedo a que la
violencia se disparara sin control
[Música]
al azar
llevamos 15 días en el bosque hace mucho
frío
esta es una llamada de auxilio de una
mujer iraquí es uno de los miles de
emigrantes que están atrapados en el
bosque entre belarús y polonia la puerta
de entrada a la unión europea la página
de facebook y unified 'rescue recibe
decenas de mensajes de este tipo cada
semana esta es gestionada por
voluntarios que intentan ayudar a los
migrantes comunicando sus coordenadas de
gps a las ong humanitarias la página fue
creada por un joven iraquí también
migrante que llegó a alemania en 2015
aceptó hablar con nosotros de forma
anónima por su propia seguridad por
haber tenido hace poco recibimos una
llamada de un grupo de migrantes en su
mayoría yemeníes que llevaban varios
días atrapados en la frontera entre
belarús y polonia no tenían comida ni
agua hacía mucho frío
[Música]
y avisamos a la cruz roja de belarús
pero la ong nos dijo que los guardias
fronterizos les impidieron ayudar
también recibimos una llamada de socorro
de una mujer con sus hijos que habían
dormido varios días en el bosque estaban
en el lado de belarús se notificó a la
agencia de naciones unidas para
refugiados y a la cruz roja normalmente
es muy difícil ayudar a la gente del
lado de belarús los guardias fronterizos
se niegan a ayudarlos oa dejarlos volver
a minsk capital de belarús para los
inmigrantes un teléfono podría ser la
última oportunidad para sobrevivir
por favor dese prisa mi hijo perdió el
conocimiento solo tiene nueve años no
tenemos cobijas ni leña ni comida ni
agua
pero algunas veces la batería se acaba
'la y no volvió a recibir noticias de
esta familia ni sabemos qué pasó con la
pequeña estos equipos también reciben
numerosas llamadas de personas que
intentan cruzar el mar
también recibimos muchas de socorro
desde el mar en la mañana del 21 de
octubre recibimos una llamada de un
grupo de 26 personas entre ellas un niño
al barco le estaba entrando agua
alertamos a los guardacostas italianos y
ellos lo rescataron el 8 de octubre
recibimos los llamadas cerca de marmaris
dos barcos con 27 y 11 inmigrantes a
bordo
notificamos a los guardacostas turcos y
ambas embarcaciones fueron rescatadas
tengo un mensaje para los migrantes no
les digo vayan a europa o váyanse a casa
pero deben saber que están arriesgando
sus vidas
es todo por esta semana y los
observadores de france 24 si ustedes
quieren entrar en contacto con la
producción del programa nuestros
contactos en whatsapp en twitter y de
correo electrónico aparecen en sus
pantallas esperamos sus fotos y sus
vídeos nos vemos la próxima semana hasta
entonces